to get the ball back so one steal leads
to the other homegrown up top and down
have to happen for the jazz the ball has
to move
and they could have to find an answer
for the unicorn
for chet holmen out there
he gives it off to
holmgren back inside there's the passing
skill set of chet holmgren yeah jasmine
having to work for those kind of shots
right here that highlighting chat again
amazing
first bucket here in the second
he's such an intelligent player with
that ball in his hand holdren one-on-one
against law
takes the bump now
jumper pulls the string you know you've
watched the game you've watched dirk
nowitzki take the hit and fade back
chet holmgren
here's law baseline
takes it right at holmgren we talk about
being aggressive
law tries to climb the mountain is
another rejection for the big man that's
three in this half and he's taking it
right off
final two minutes here in vegas
one more game to come we'll have the
pelicans and the blazers next another
block for chet holmgren a a huge key for
playing with a guy like giddy
homegrin slips the screen
got open slams it home
great chemistry between those two to
find that cutter
on that rip screen up top for a layup we
try to get one a game
homegrown with a side step three butter
seven foot one the total package
homegrown defensively but offensively he
was one of the most efficient players in
college basketball last year thought
they were going to have an alley-oop but
terry had a body on holmgren prevented
that from happening
simpson with the miss holmgren
packing that one on the glass he's not
making that spin move to score
holmgren wow holy cow
that's a great find and then j dub
finds holmgren
it wasn't really a great
simpson get them into a set
a little misdirection for houston to get
a bit away
oh boy nice block by chet holmgren so
both guys showing a little bit of
everything here early on
right down main street for the
two-handed flush guys that play with him
know he's looking to set them up
man the three
nice fine from hogan that was a high
level of let that 7-3 folk thunder fans
can appreciate through the legs then on
the attack
that is a really difficult play to make
one thing that makes the pass